okay babies we're gonna do this one I'm
gonna get some bull Iman fur it's a
tough one level 5 on level 4 but you
know I was trying whatever and what some
finds a blue monk for so he may decorate
his hat with it we can gunfire the
finish off with me lay whoo okay African
far ways okay I could do that I guess
man is that like a freaking fast travel
if there is that kind of freaking get
one oh my god thing
yeah you see a freaking far this is holy
God anyway there's one right there
all right yes that is how many do I did
four so I gotta get all of them this is
crazy
can I not die from bent Heights anyway I
was just over here so we just go over
and get this guy get the hell out of
here okay come on
all right yeah all right yeah
oh my god
well I'm gonna die now we're gonna die
I'm gonna die
I'm stuck
well okay I got ya okay I'm doing that
wait can I just like punch it that body
and get it or no let me just try really
quick no I can't do that freaking night
okay that was close
I should just weaken them all with this
my breath when they go in you know what
else ice how do I get over there
what the hell like a head seeing it get
some of this bad boy
okay I'm gonna do what this one is it no
what is it oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's gonna take like 10
years like the wars my son
okay he'll have one this town per
episode though so let me just check this
out whoa what's in here
I'm saying it in here oh crap
[ __ ]
where how's everyone now who's shutting
me
someone shot aiming and I don't like it
well okay I can't pick that's how pick
this up I came down again again there's
so much stuff over here if it takes like
ten takes to cut ours up pick everything
out you mean got away from some with
stuff like that how do I open this eat
it scram
is there like something I could like get
like oh the master control stations
gotta be around here somewhere all right
see what's up here whoa what is this
- [ __ ] ok here we get this but like half
its let's play it's just like any
gathering load it's crazy it's crazy
other way in there
okay what the hell
every way to sneak in all right
what's this slippery path Oh bully mom
perfect bring your friends place please
bring your friends Michael backpack
time oh wow
yeah BAM bang okay no I don't want a
shotgun I want a sniper rifle well my
guys like dying AJ's not there unto God
hey it's just not to second-class gonna
take like ten hours to get that
come on
what that house hey huh yeah
I know what's left of their face yeah
got it baby
whoa all right thank you for watching